the number of uh rioters
arrested and charged from the january
6th trump insurrectionist riots is
growing and growing and growing
and there is a very interesting story
well reported in the new york times
about a guy named jackson referet
and jackson referet knew that his dad
guy refit uh was in washington d.c
for the riots and two days after the
riots on january 6
guy refit returned home to the family's
house
in texas and he told his son i was there
i was there on january 6 i stormed the
capitol
and guy threatened his own son jackson
and said jackson jackson's 18. jackson
if you report me to the police
i'm going to have no choice but to do my
duty for this country and quote do what
i have to do
jackson went to the fbi and jackson told
investigators that uh his dad had been
there
and that he stormed the capitol and that
he threatened him and said if you turn
me in you're a traitor
and traitors get shot
incredibly this was not the first
contact that jackson had with the fbi
about his dad
weeks before the riot um
jackson went to the fbi and said
my dad keeps telling me he's going to do
something big and this is yet another
one of those
instances where we find out and again
the fbi
very busy with reports all the time the
fbi is getting reports uh
from all sorts of different people all
the time about different things
but this is not a guy who no one thought
maybe had the capacity to do this
jackson refit had already told uh
law enforcement that his dad was
claiming he was going to do
something big uh guy refit's wife said
to investigators
after the riot that a guy is a member of
the three percenters this is a far-right
militia group according to the fbi
affidavit
when fbi agents went to the referet
house they found an ar-15 rifle
and a pistol and the elder
rephit told investigators i did bring
the pistol with me to washington where
he is
as far as we know not licensed to have a
weapon
and this is an incredible story because
number i mean this is a story about so
many things number one it's yet another
one of these stories of hey
we told authorities in advance and they
failed
to do something that is a story that has
been told many times
and we could devote an hour to that on
its own limited resources
etc etc this is also an incredible story
about a kid legally now an adult 18 but
but
someone who has been observing their
father mostly as a kid
knowing that their dad was up to no good
and because politics tends to run in
families
the kids tend to have the same political
beliefs as the parents
the reality that uh jackson
not only recognized that what his dad
was doing was wrong
um actually had the i don't know if i
would call it audacity but but maybe
it's strength maybe the conviction to
say
it's more important that i tell the
police what it is my dad
is doing even though uh even even though
he's my dad
and we don't know whether the fbi did
anything at all about the reports that
came in
prior to the january 6th riot we know
that federal investigators
contacted him uh during the riots
contacted the sun during the riots to
follow up on the tips from
from weeks earlier and said uh we need
your help
to prove what we're now trying to
investigate and
it is an unbelievable you know we i get
calls all the time about
my family disagrees with me and they
voted for trump and i didn't and i just
want to talk to them and try to talk
sense into them
this is like another layer altogether
and i think many of us i mean listen i i
would like to think
that if one of my parents was involved
in something like this
i would go to the authorities am i sure
that i would i mean listen if it was
murder yeah i would
um i i don't know what the line is for
me and so
imagining being in jackson refits
position is just
just just incredible and uh now of
course
the elder refered is going to have to
face the consequences partially as a
result of the fact
that his son did the right thing and it
think about the bizarre nature of the
times we are living in
the the the traditional trope is the
parents worry about
what are what's my kid doing on the
internet is my kid getting radicalized
on the internet i don't know
started spending a lot of time in their
room typically his room it's
typically men not women spending time in
his room on
on the internet and then had all these
ideas and i don't know what was going on
this is a reversal kids are having to
make the decision to turn their parents
in when their parents have become
radicalized by
you know internet news media messages
truly unbelievable times that we live in
not an easy position to be in and we
will ultimately see at the tail end of
this
how many of the charges stick and how
many people are actually
held accountable and suffer a
consequence for what they did
a lot of these cases are going to be
difficult
to approve in terms of the most serious
charges that could be brought we already
talked about
sedition and other charges that require
proving intent and that's going to be
tough
so uh jackson refit doing the right
thing
let's hope it actually leads to charges
that stick because clearly
uh guy ref it a very very dangerous guy
let me know your thoughts about this and
it really is tragic
i don't see this and say hahaha i see
this and say
wow a family member placed in an
impossible position about their parent
because of the radicalization coming as
a result of this trump
uh cult that has taken place let me know
what you think i'm on twitter at
deepakman
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon click the link right underneath
this video